[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
en esta oportunidad quiero presentarles
dos historias que hablan de inmigrantes
que crean su propia manera de sobrevivir
y que no se dejan vencer por las
dificultades en sus viajes a la
seguridad los migrantes refugiados y
desplazados deben sortear un sinnúmero
de obstáculos que se les presentan al
dejar su hogar y en ese recorrido
aprenden a adaptarse y a volver a
empezar ese es el caso de un grupo de
sirios refugiados en jordania que
olvidaron sus viejas profesiones y
aprendieron de agricultura hidropónica
una oportunidad para cultivar su propio
alimento y contribuir a su nueva
comunidad la del campo de refugiados
desatar y que alberga casi 76 mil
personas entre ellas a unos 40 mil niños
esta es la historia
a kilómetros de su natal siria estos
refugiados cultivan menta tomates y
pepinos
y lo hacen en cultivos hidropónicos
usando semillas agua y algunos colchones
viejos
aprendieron de agricultura hidropónica
ante las condiciones desérticas del
suelo jordano una habilidad que les
permite cosechar su propio alimento
el proyecto tiene varios objetivos y
resultados positivos
[Música]
para empezar nos permite ser
autosuficientes
también ahorramos agua este proyecto
agrícola puede ser implementado en
espacios pequeños o con mucha gente a
día
en cuanto a los productos son todos 100%
naturales y puros sin químicos ni
hormonas por lo que las frutas y
verduras que producimos son 100%
saludables elimina this world es un
método de plantación versátil que no
necesita de las propiedades de la tierra
atmar llegó a jordania junto a su esposa
y sus seis hijos y ahora está feliz de
poder retomar su antiguo oficio como
agricultor
me encanta trabajar en este proyecto
porque lo disfruto pasar tiempo entre
las plantas y trabajar con vegetales es
diferente a trabajar en la construcción
así que disfruto esto especialmente
porque el proceso es tecnológicamente
avanzado y limpio la agricultura
tradicional está llena de barro y arena
esto solo es agua
venimos limpios y nos vamos limpio ni a
uno dice me da bien y yo no defino lo
bueno de final
el sistema hidropónico consume entre un
70 y 80 por ciento menos de agua que los
métodos tradicionales de plantación algo
importante en un país con escasez de
líquido y una oportunidad de trabajo
para los refugiados
siempre tratamos de implementar ideas
que ayuden a la comunidad local ya los
sirios de ahí el suelo en el campo de
sal lari no es apto para la agricultura
así que decidimos experimentar con
nuevas tecnologías que ayuden a los
refugiados
por lo que pueden implementar este
proceso a tiempo cuando regresen fijas
los salva villava lejos según acnur más
de 1500 sirios fueron capacitados en
cultivos hidropónicos muchos de ellos
comenzaron sus propios proyectos
y de jordania vamos hasta colombia édgar
álvarez es un artista que literalmente
moldea realidades difíciles de contar él
trabaja en un gran proyecto contra la
xenofobia con el que busca acercar a los
colombianos y a los migrantes
venezolanos
édgar nos lo explica con plastilina una
figura que por estos días es bastante
popular llama la atención en algunas
calles de bogotá parece acechar a su
próximo objetivo pero en realidad no
supone ningún peligro detrás de esta
representación en plastilina está édgar
álvarez un colombiano que busca
visibilizar el drama de la migración de
cientos de venezolanos hacia su país
lo hace ubicando esta figura cerca de
los lugares donde comúnmente los
migrantes se rebuscan la vida en puestos
callejeros después hago mucha fotografía
como
de las de muchos inmigrantes en espacios
reales porque pues es ha sido con una de
las cosas claves como dentro de esto sea
como darle esa realidad vamos a ubicar
con muchos de los de estos personajes en
los sitios donde pasan las cosas durante
25 años ha creado figuras de plastilina
siendo la migración uno de sus
principales temas de interés tal vez
porque vivió lo que significa estar en
un paisaje no durante seis años esto nos
ha cambiado como en tantos aspectos que
puse es fundamental como poderlos
mostrar y ahí es donde te toca como
explicarlos un poco con con plastilina
pero además de la plastilina descubren
la animación lo que le hacía falta para
recrear la realidad de los que huyen y
para hacerlo acompaño a algunos de ellos
en parte de su ex
cuando yo estudié artes plásticas que es
obviamente mis maestras medias no pescó
a oficio porque eso es para niños si te
quedas ayer de esas vainas y todo y te
resulta que ahorita pues tenemos una
página pues que tienen una cobertura
grandísima brillo trabajo con
organizaciones de todo el de todo el
mundo colabora con organismos como la
cruz roja internacional y acnur con la
agencia viajó en 2019 a centroamérica y
evidenció el fenómeno migratorio hacia
estados unidos
con sus figuras busca acercar a los
colombianos y venezolanos llama a
rechazar la xenofobia y quiere poner en
relieve la realidad de los extranjeros
que se quedaron en colombia y que luchan
para sobrevivir en tiempos de pandemia
édgar sigue contando historias de
migración con plastilina con las que
busca visibilizar las condiciones de los
que huyen en los países de acogida y el
dato de migración de la semana es una
carta
los niños que siguen te entendidos en
las fronteras queremos que este plan que
ustedes tiene amigos en los eeuu que se
preocupan por ustedes con 55 mil
mariposas de papel niños de todo el
mundo se solidarizan con los menores
inmigrantes encerrados en centros de
detención en eeuu con este vídeo
titulado todavía luchando por ti les
dicen no están solos y piden su libertad
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan conectados con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]